okay
we're going to
see how we can extend our maximal margin
classifier now to deal with situations
where you cannot separate the data well
so
we'll start off
in the case with the data
aren't separable at all as we see in
this picture over here
okay well all good and well
what happens if the data aren't
separable i mean it's a little bit
wishful thinking that that we can always
separate the data perfectly with the
hyper plane
so here's a similar picture to what we
had before and in this case the data
aren't separable
you'll see you cannot fit a hyperplane
through these data
and exactly separate them you can try as
much as you like but you know there's
maybe an attempt but no
you always you can just it's obvious
you're always going to get you're always
going to get overlap
and and this is often the case
especially if the number
of points is large relative to the
dimensions
on the other hand
for a lot of wide data like in genomics
and other kinds of problems
the number of sample points is less than
the dimensions and in general when the
number of sample points is less than the
dimensions you can always separate the
data with a hyper plane
okay so
but but when n is much bigger than p
typically not
so that's a problem we need to deal with
another problem we're going to want to
deal with is when you have noisy data
and so i alluded to that earlier
so here we've got our original data and
it's not too noisy and we get a hyper
plane over there what happens if we add
one more point blue point
here it is over here
and now we still want to separate in
hyperplane well just the presence of
that one extra point means we've had to
tilt the hyperplane quite dramatically
to still get separation
so that's a little bit of crazy behavior
we'd say non-robust behavior to the
addition of one extra point this point
might be an outlier and it's going to
have a dramatic effect on the on the
on the maximal margin classifier
so we want to be able to deal with those
both of these problems
this
what we call a support vector classifier
is going to do that and it maximizes
what we call a soft margin so we're
going to relax the idea of of a separate
and hyperplane
okay
so here's the idea we've got two
pictures here both of them have soft
margins
in the left picture the data actually
are separable
but we've made the margin wider than we
need to
and so we've got two points on the wrong
side of their margins
amongst the blue guys this point here
number eight is on the wrong side of the
margin this one
right
and amongst the the pink guys
this guy is on the wrong side of the
margin
but by getting the the margin wider
we've had to put up with those two those
two so-called errors and so we call this
a soft margin
and the idea is that making the soft
margin wider or smaller
is a is a way of of kind of regularizing
because
once you allow some points to be on the
wrong side of the margin the margin gets
determined by more than just the closest
points
the right plot
it's essential to have a soft margin
because we cannot get a separate in
hyperplane
and so here we have a candidate
hyper plane with its margins and we see
that there's several
points on the wrong side
we've got a blue point on the wrong side
of its margin over here
we've got a blue point on the wrong side
of the decision boundary and on the
wrong side of the margin likewise
there's a move point
on the wrong side of of the decision
boundary also wrong side of the margin
so these are called soft margins
and we need to modify
the
the formulation of the problem to
accommodate it
so the part of the problem is the same
we're going to maximize n subject to the
beta's summing squares 1 so that's a
unit vector
now we want all the points the distance
of all the points be bigger than m but
discounted by a discount factor
1 minus epsilon i so we allow some slack
some points needn't be
exactly bigger than the margin but there
can be some slack
and how do we
account for all the slack we give
ourselves a budget
we give ourselves a budget for the total
amount of slack which in this case is c
so the epsilons tell us how much each
point is allowed to be on the wrong side
of its margin it's a relative amount
relative to the margin
and we give ourselves a number c a total
amount of overlap and then subject to
that we're going to make the margin as
wide as possible
to get on either side of the margin
okay again convex optimization problem
we can solve using the svm package in r
c is now tuning parameter
and as we change c the soft margin is
going to get wider or smaller
so as i said it's a regularization
parameter and so here we've got four
scenarios where we've changed c here's
the bigger c
and in fact it's the biggest
a possible c that that's needed because
now all points on the wrong side of the
margin
okay
and and so there's an epsilon for every
single point
um so these epsilons you can think of as
let's do it in this picture over here
you can draw arrows
which which tells you the distance of
each point from the margin
okay so there's one for this guy
and the length
of these is proportional to to to the
epsilons and likewise for these guys
okay
and as we tighten c
the margin gets tighter because we're
allowing less and less overlap
and so that becomes a tuning parameter
we'll see a little bit later that in
effect the number of points that are on
the wrong side of the margin in other
side with all the points inside the
margin or on the wrong side of the
margin become
the effective points that are
controlling the orientation of the
margin
so in some sense the more points that
are involved in the orientation of the
margin the more stable it becomes
and that means as c gets bigger the more
stable the margin becomes
and so there's going to be a kind of a
bias variance trade-off as we change c
so it's really sorry regular
organization permit rob well it's not a
question actually yeah thinking i mean
we're taking the euclidean distance and
all these pictures is does it matter if
i standardize the variables first should
i standardize the variables first oh
that's a good point yes you know i think
i think you you're right rob
um
the the sport vector machine treats all
the variables as equals in a way and so
the units count so good point the
variable should be standardized
if you remember when we did the lasso
and ridge regression we said that was
important there too well the same for
the same reasons it's important here
well so we've come up with a compromise
when when the points overlap but in some
cases no matter how much we try that
compromise isn't going to help and so
here's a
there's a fake situation but it's a
situation where
having a soft margin doesn't help you
can see we've got a the move set of
points is exactly in the middle of a
crowd of blues on one side and another
crowd of blues on the other side
and no matter what we do we will we
won't get a good classifier
what we'd like to do is bend the margin
and we're going to talk about ways of
how we do that in in the next segment